autorisé à fleurir les tombes de leurs
proches plusieurs personnes ont profité
du week end de la toussaint pour venir
se recueillir comme ce dimanche au
cimetière des gones arts de versailles
je suis partie rendre hommage à mes
arrière-grands-parents donc du coup
c'est important surtout en cette période
en fait donc du coup voilà je suis venu
je lui demande de bon matin pour déposer
des fleurs sur leur trouve on vient
assez régulièrement mais aux jouets
c'est la coutume quelques on puisse
venir en dehors de la tout ça mais on
aime bien venir ce jour là contrairement
aux premiers confinement les cimetières
devrait rester ouverts une décision
importante selon les visiteurs pour
pouvoir être dans l'ambiance du
cimetière de se rapprocher des tons de
l'est d'abord de les nettoyer aussi de
voir toutes ces jolies fleurs de voir
que tout le monde pense à ces morts la
semaine du travail dont je peux pas
venir donc c'est très bien que c'est
ouvert le samedi dimanche et le double à
tous sans forcément après ce week-end de
la toussaint il sera donc possible de se
rendre au cimetière
en cochant la case motif familial
impérieux de l'attestation